l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 404 de Madame Catherine
trindley un monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais chers collègues je
souhaiterais attirer votre attention
monsieur le ministre sur le projet de
fermeture de la section baccalauréat
professionnel commerce au sein du lycée
Joseph vogue de Masevaux dans l'unique
lycée de la vallée de Masevaux la
fermeture de cette section obligerait
les élèves à se déplacer bien plus loin
sur Mulhouse il est tenu pour certains
que les résultats scolaires de nombreux
élèves subissant un tel rythme s'en
ferait ressentir cette formation
dispensée depuis trois ans enregistre un
taux de réussite de 100%.
l'établissement secondaire peut
également se targuer d'avoir obtenu la
moitié des mentions très bien décrochées
dans le Haut-Rhin lors de la session
d'examen de 2012 pourquoi dès lors
vouloir fermer une section qui donne
pleine et entière satisfaction
à l'heure où chaque année quelques 150
000 jeunes sortent du système scolaire
sans aucune qualification il demeure
essentielle de promouvoir cette
formation de proximité porteuse d'avenir
pour nos jeunes
la directrice académique des services de
l'éducation nationale du Haut-Rhin tout
comme l'inspecteur académie de la
circonscription se sont rendus sur place
afin d'échanger sur le devenir de cette
formation je salue bien évidemment cette
volonté de dialogue auprès du corps
enseignant mais cette fermeture relève
des plus hautes instances et c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre je vous
demande de ne pas vous arrêter à une
seule quantification mathématique des
effectifs il faut considérer l'aspect
humain et non comptable du problème
l'argument avancé relatif au manque
d'effectif n'est en rien recevable aussi
je m'interroge comment faire en sorte
d'augmenter les effectifs si la filière
devait disparaître le maintien de cette
section correspond à une forte demande
sur notre territoire aussi je vous
demande quelle suite souhaitez-vous
donner à la pérennisation de cette
filière dispensée au lycée de Masevaux
je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Vincent payant ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice
le constat que vous avez rappelé
concernant
les 140 000 jeunes qui chaque année
sortent de nos systèmes éducatifs sans
qualification
est un constat que nous connaissons que
nous partageons et cette situation et
bien insupportable c'est pourquoi je
vous rejoins pleinement dans la
nécessité de lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire et j'ai fixé comme objectif de
faire dès cette année raccrocher 20 000
jeunes en prenant appui vous le savez
sur les 360 plateformes de suivi que mon
prédécesseur avait installé nous avons
rendu le dispositif plus réactif et
cohérent nous avons mieux coordonné les
acteurs et d'ores et déjà nous avons des
résultats significatifs cet objectif que
j'avais indiqué sera donc atteint et
nous pouvons nous en réjouir je suis là
suppose aussi la rationalisation des
moyens supplémentaires que le Président
de la République a accordé fait
exceptionnel depuis depuis longtemps à
l'éducation nationale
s'agissant plus particulièrement de la
situation du lycée professionnel Joseph
vogue je souhaite vous donner les
informations suivantes ce lycée
professionnel rencontre depuis plusieurs
années des difficultés de recrutement
que je vais détailler il dispose
actuellement d'une capacité de 69 places
pour 4 secondes professionnels section
accompagnement soins et services à la
personne taux de remplissage
100%, 30 élèves section commerce s'est
inscrit pour 12 places filières gestion
des administrations 8 inscrits pour 12
places et les électrotechniques 12
inscrit pour 15 places dans ce contexte
il est apparu nécessaire de rééquilibrer
la carte des formations en fermant ce
baccalauréat professionnel commerce lors
de la prochaine rentrée je vous précise
que seul 4 élèves quatre élèves
l'avaient demandé en vœu numéro un à la
dernière rentrée
la fermeture de cette section permettra
sans toucher au moyen du lycée je vais y
revenir de mieux privilégier la
cohérence de notre carte de formation au
sein de l'académie et ça c'est la
réussite aussi des élèves sans perturber
l'organisation de vie des lycéens en
effet les élèves du secteur de ma faute
qui sont peu nombreux devraient être
accueillis en seconde professionnelle
commerce au lycée de Thann situé à 30
minutes en transport scolaire au-delà je
tiens à vous rassurer car vous avez eu
cette inquiétude légitime sur l'avenir
du lycée la capacité d'accueil pose 3e
restera intégralement préservé car nous
allons ouvrir un cap assistant technique
en milieu familial et collectif qui aura
la même capacité de 12 élèves cela
permettra à l'établissement une
cohérence puisque dans le secteur des
services à la personne il aura la
filière complète du CAP au baccalauréat
professionnel il contribuera ainsi à
renforcer la cohérence de notre offre de
formation nous partageons des objectifs
nous savons que même pour quatre élèves
c'est sans doute une difficulté mais
nous améliorons l'offre de formation et
nous nous engageons vous l'avez vu par
le dialogue dans la liaison avec les
autorités académiques avec les élus à
faire en sorte que les uns et les autres
les parents les élèves les élus
comprennent que nous agissons dans
l'intérêt même des élèves et de votre
département
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
trindelet
ce ministre j'aimerais d'abord vous
remercier pour la précision de votre de
votre réponse très argumentée je vois
que vous êtes bien documenté concernant
la situation de ce lycée bien sûr nous
partageons tous ensemble ici présent
la même ambition celle de porter nos
jeunes jusqu'à un emploi la vous dites
qu'il n'y aura aucun impact pour les
jeunes bien sûr qu'il y aura un impact
puisqu'ils devront se déplacer vous vous
dites qu'ils pourront se déplacer
jusqu'à jusqu'au lycée Thann ils devront
trouver une solution c'est évident c'est
une vallée un petit peu particulière
assez difficile d'accès il est vrai
qu'il y en a que quatre qui se sont
inscrits mais en fermant cette section
peut-être que et en annonçant la
fermeture de section peut-être que cela
n'a pas motivé les jeunes à s'y inscrire
en tous les cas je partage comme vous
monsieur le ministre cette ambition que
nous partageons tous ensemble celle de
porter nos jeunes le plus loin possible
dans une qualification pour qu'il puisse
acquérir un métier une formation qui les
qui les emmènera jusqu'à un emploi merci
merci Madame